So, who sits on Discord all day trying
to make friends? Chromos and bed blobs.
But I see another route. If you're
wasting your life on Discord, sit up
straight and make something. It's
actually pretty easy. And what do you
need really? A microphone. You have a
computer already. The software is free.
So, really, the barrier to entry is
being as technically competent and
intelligent as sensitive society. And
what a better time to be making content.
There's an online cult of Indians on the
loose, led by a Cuban [__] with
potential stimulant induced
schizophrenia. There's an obese Italian
stealing every single concept he can
from real creators and then cheerleading
lawsuits that could destroy this whole
platform. And what are the people that
see this as a problem actually doing?
Sitting on Discord and complaining about
it all day or you going to find a nice
clip on Twitter and make them look
silly? No. Stop being lazy. Step up and
make some commentary videos. Imagine
Sensitive Society, but his videos aren't
a consistently worthless croc of [__]
You could take this commentary slop
formula, but just have funny jokes and
good takes. But then, I don't even think
it should be considered slop at that
point. I don't think people should have
ever embraced slop. It was funny when
Dolan Dark first started saying it, but
you hear now people repeating, "Ooh, I
love drama slop." Echoing off of that, I
hear, "Yeah, I am [__] Actually,
I'm just a stupid [__] feed me my slop.
And I believe this devalues what can be
the true essence of this platform.
Passionate people just in their houses
creating scuffed but novel and original
content that breaks the mold of the
corporate hegemony. If a real person has
charisma and something decent to say,
them talking for 10 minutes should not
be slop. But I am partly hijacking these
takes from someone that people have a
lot of strong feelings about. But this
is a PPP from another era, another
lifetime. it feels like when it comes to
content creation now. And I'm aware I'm
at risk of making a fool of myself by
taking anything they say too seriously.
But PPP talking about the Kino Dogma
2007 and some of the content him and
Godwinson created from this was epic.
Here he looks back to creators that are
before my time. But these guys wouldn't
have any quality equipment or recording
software and they would just record
themselves in one take talking about
something. At this time, PPP looks back
at this as the only honest content on
this platform. So, he lays out these
rules that he thinks people should
follow to emulate this. The main rules
were that people should not use a
script. They should not use any editing.
They should not ebeg. They should show
their face and have a basic camera
setup. They should record a video in one
take and leave in any flubbed lines. And
video shouldn't be any longer than 10
minutes. These rules weren't strictly
followed, but him and Godwinson did
create a lot of content just yelling
into their phones. They were normal
people talking about their passions,
calling people out and most importantly
just talking [__] on the internet. They
were incredibly niche, but they also
managed to really [__] rattle people
just by making these videos or streaming
from a phone and flipping the phone
around and recording their computer
screen instead of using OBS. I don't
wish to label the point, but there is
something
of the soul with Boogie's surroundings
here. You may have seen him in recent
videos. The backdrop is a $1,000 Master
Sword.
Merchandise that would cost anyone who
wished to buy it thousands and thousands
of dollars.
Instead, what we've got here is a is a
sort of scuffed princess layer from
Return of the Jedi lying down half
naked. You've got an unmade bed. This
has more soul in it than anything he's
produced in a decade. And yeah, I'd have
preferred it quite a lot if Godwinson
did just use a conventional streaming
setup. Clearly, I am not ideologically
attached to creating content in this
way. But I think looking back at this,
it is clear something has been lost. We
now live in a world of fake YouTube. And
I do think it should be respected that
they managed to go against the corporate
trends of this platform. And despite
their many flaws, I don't know all of
the law, okay? They managed to be the
guy and get their voices heard just
using their phones. But alas, Godwinson
is gone from the internet now. And PPP
does not keep the spirit of the Kino
Dogme 2007 alive.
>> What happened to you, man?
No, but really, what happened to that
guy? That guy sounds like me. That guy
sounds a lot like me. What happened to
that [__] guy? Am I going to end up a
jaded old boomer chain smoking
cigarettes with some Asian [__] pig,
you know, trying to scam you guys for 8
grand a month? Is that what's going to
happen? I [__] hope not. Let's all
[__] pray to God that I stick to the
true and honest path of the Kino Dogme.
It's scary. That guy sounds like That
guy sounds reasonable. Isn't it [__]
UP
AND WELCOME BACK TO ANOTHER EPISODE of
Content Cop. I would hazard a guess that
defect from the Yandere Dev cult Cameron
F305, similarly to libs slave Willie
Mack show had no idea who PPP was until
recently. Oh my god, they've just popped
up out of nowhere. In the realm of the
commentary community, this muttering
video in the style of retro Idubbbz is
peak fake YouTube. Semantics aside, in
my opinion, Jeremy is an unprincipled
[__] coward who griffs to the right.
Not only because that's where his
political beliefs lie, but also because
that's where he makes the most money.
>> One of the reasons why he grifts to the
right is because that's where his
political beliefs lie. Even if his
script wasn't total [__] and his bits
weren't complete hack garbage. Even if
this guy was honestly interested in the
quartering and he wasn't just chasing
drama that was doing good numbers, just
going off the presentation and delivery
that this rapist chooses to use, you
should be able to tell this is
inauthentic garbage.
>> Other examples of Jeremy's cowardly
behavior come from his need to insert
himself into YouTube drama.
>> PPP knows this. He hasn't forgot the
last 10 years of his life, but now he
applauds it. Ana Jamha's husband,
Idubbbz, otherwise known as Ian.
>> That edit and it was funny the way the
edit was on her and then slide it over.
>> It's hard not to be blackpilled and not
just put the makeup on, be the clown,
and cash in the check. But there must be
a limit. These people that have
applauded this in a quest to keep things
easy, in a quest to keep the popular
narrative alive, to maximize the
accumulation of shekels, have failed.
Now, I disagree with the PPP of old. I
think people should make their money.
Ebegging obviously can get so egregious
that it needs to be called out, but if
you want to make enough money to live a
modest life, own a little fixer uper,
then more power to you. But I can't
imagine anything more gross than selling
out all your principles so you can buy a
tacky [__] watch.
>> Let me take a look.
>> It's that size. So Ethan's now an expert
because, you know, for a month he's
Googled most expensive watch and then
went out and bought it. He's now an
expert. You know, he's got the jeweler's
glass.
>> [__] bro. You got you wanted.
>> She's got the biggest smile ever once
she seems the gleam of the gold. Look at
this.
>> Nice size.
>> Runso.
>> You got the one you wanted.
>> That's what I wanted.
>> It's not as nice as ours, but it's still
got your half watch. And
>> of course, fluted. Well, if you're not
going to go fluted on the date, just you
want to put oyster on it, like an oyster
bracelet, why not just get an OP, it's
one like, who really needs the date on
their watch? At that point, you can get
an OP36 and save like 2,000 bucks. And I
I understand you're not saving money
when you want a Rolex. You're buying it
for a status symbol.
>> Commentary YouTube and anything adjacent
to it should be kept far away from the
realm of celebrity. When looking at this
old episode of the H3 podcast when I was
making my video for Harley Mournstein,
it was quite surprising to look back and
hear them talk about going to Coachella
with Post Malone as if this was just a
normal outing for these YouTubers turned
celebrities.
But now this has all been torn away from
them. Ethan never even got a chance to
show off his new ompic chic when rubbing
shoulders with pop stars. And the price
that we pay for this as normie YouTube
viewers is that what was once humble
YouTube drama, what used to be simply
one autistic man sat in his house
calling out another Sonic fan for his
bad take is now a millionaire in a bair
mansion not making commentary videos but
trying to sue people to oblivion. Why
doesn't he make videos? Well, if he
needed to appeal to Keemstar's audience,
maybe he would. But Local Live does not
inform the cultural zeitgeist of the
celebrities in the VIP area of
Coachella. In an old video that I made
that honestly isn't very good, I talk
about the angry video game nerd and how
he dealt with his well, if you're a
complete, you'd call it a snark
subreddit. And I praise James for almost
completely ignoring these Redditors as a
great way to deal with this. I'm sure if
James went about this differently and he
spent what years live streaming weekly
talking about this subreddit and his
enemies, he'd probably by now have been
trolled into becoming a shell of a
human. There is a harrowing alternative
reality where James took the path of the
lolcow, but he just ignored it. So, in
James' and the angry video game nerds
reality, it pretty much doesn't exist.
But this would not work for Ethan. You
see, James is a humble family man. He
lives a normal life almost entirely
offline. But ignoring this doesn't work
for someone that has maxed out their
money and is now looking to climb
socially in the world of celebrity.
Ethan shouldn't be looking at [__] pics
whilst playing poker, but he also now
can't escape the celebrity world that he
so desperately tried to be a part of.
Ethan may have so much money he can
throw it around in the most despicable
and go ways, but he's never going to get
back that status of celebrity. He's
never going to be able to go back to
Coachella and network with the stars.
And you know what? He never should have
had that anyway. This whole time, he's
been nothing but a creepy commentary
YouTuber, and he should have stayed in
his lane.
>> Hey, remember that video we made two or
three months ago about that black guy
that was eating and kids? Like a lot of
kids.
>> Yeah. Patrice Wilson.
>> Yeah, that was fine. That guy's
definitely a pedophile.
>> Well, it was just one video. You don't
know
>> what?
Just one video. Eli, this is Patrice
Wilson we're talking about. This is not
something that someone just does once.
If we went to his YouTube channel right
now, I guarantee we click one random
video and he's going to be on the ground
rolling around touching and tickling
with a little girl. Dude, are you
seriously trying to tell me that you
don't think Patrice Wilson is a P?
>> I guess.
>> Come on, dude. It doesn't make sense,
dude. What did you write? Is this a
secret message to your ring?
Sick, dude. All these different
languages is a hidden message to all
your friends to come meet you
underground at your rape dungeon where
you guys can exchange egg rolls, if you
know what I mean. This guy now is a
multi-millionaire and he is suing
Idubbbz for showing a message that
Destiny wrote to his horde of Indians
and no one is saying anything because
Idubbbz is a lol cow. That is the
popular message. That is the path of
least resistance and all of the bottom
feeders that are below Ethan must also
say this to uphold the house of cards
that is fake YouTube. And look, maybe
fake YouTube was inevitable. Mr. Beast
claims to have figured out that once you
grow over a certain size that showing
any personality will actually stagnate
further growth. It is entertaining.
She's a naturally funny person. At the
same time, you're limited by your
personality. She's doing well. She's top
1% of creators. It's great. It's
phenomenal, but it's like there's only
so big that can take you. She's tied
down to her personality. If you don't
like Emma, then you're not going to
watch her videos. There is a great
monetary incentive to just upholding the
popular opinion and becoming an NPC. And
now with many commentary creators
reaching the cap of their growth, they
are no personality maxing in an attempt
to reach further profit. And the only
thing that can stop fake commentary and
the scourge of celebrity is for new
creators to come along and shift the
tectonic plates. Sitting at the
sidelines and taking shots at someone
isn't going to work when they are too
big to fail. I think the only real thing
that can change is people growing and
becoming bigger than them, taking away
their relevancy. So, do you want to be
popular in the Discord? That's going to
translate well to you being popular in
the wing of the prison. You want to be
the next Twitter account? You want to be
the next Yeet. Oh, that sounds awesome.
Good luck with that. Or do you want to
be an epic real guy talking [__] on the
internet? videos as well, not streaming.
If you're gay and you want to be a gay
streamer, then keep your Chomo Discord
and post on Twitter all day for
attention. If you do make videos and
you're maintaining a Discord and you
find you don't have the time to make
stuff, delete your [__] Discord.
Delete your Circle Jerk Discord. Get on
the Sigma grind set and make some
videos. All right.